this is something that i stress a lot
with people who are followers of mine
they're like look at all these people
who are mindless and i'm like how are
these mindless people a threat to you
they're like trees are you like well we
can't win because there's all these
trees it's like what does that have to
do with anything
like any population an enormous
percentage of it is going to be with
people who really
are in a very fundamental way mindless
who have no
kind of inner voice who are opposed or
incapable of thinking critically the
average man does not want to be free he
simply wants to be safe
what do you mean you've been trying to
copy me
yeah because not copy you but like you
you say words in a
unique way russia russia yeah
it's the word russia that's it yeah
man is what it is how are you today you
good i'm very good
yeah man i'm excited to have you here i
want to try and get a proper
understanding of your political
position are we going away to russia
later this year later this year and i
feel like i need i need to kind of
really get my get my teeth stuck into
what you believe so what are the
principles of
your political position um
well one of the principles is that you
don't need to get into what i believe
because i think it's a very
um insidious
concept that we have to be friends with
people who agree with us or or
to discuss politics at all there's this
concept
that you know politics have to permeate
every aspect of
every person's life and you know they
have to constantly be discussed this is
something i'm completely opposed to i
think it's
it's really a horrible idea uh and it's
tribalism which i'm not
entirely opposed to at its worst uh if
you know if someone is uh if you're
having an emergency
at home you know you don't quickly run a
scan oh well i want to call this person
but they voted the wrong way or
something like that
so my political views and you're
referring to anarchism
it's simply being against politics as a
mechanism of resolving disputes
and you know everything just follows as
a consequence of that
um it's i mean i we can unpack it but
that's basically it in a nutshell
is that a typical perspective on
anarchism
uh i don't know that there is a typical
perspective there's different schools
of anarchism there's like uh i think
it's there's an anarchist lapel pins
um website and they have the
the the standard flag of anarchism is
the black flag
but there's black and red black and gold
black and pink
black and blue uh so all the different
schools of anarchism
so and they disagree very heavily
uh but it's gonna be a venn diagram yeah
i understand i mean the main reason
i wasn't necessarily trying to agree but
i'm curious i'm interested i don't
see many people saying that they're
anarchists in
2021 so what why do you find it
compelling what's interesting about it
well i think it closely
explains the what we're seeing in
politics
i think it's an effective predictor of
future
social political behavior i think it's
the only
world view that allows someone to have a
clean conscience
with what they advocate uh politically
and
i think that's just basically what it
comes down to i also want to point out
that anyone who has a radical
philosophy you know is going to come off
as either a [ __ ] or a lunatic
you know if you told me that you had a
friend who's quite tall
and i said how tall and you said you
know he's 6 10 or whatever
2.1 meters it's like okay that's pretty
tall
but if you said that they're you know 10
meters tall
or they're purple tall it's nonsensical
right
so at a certain point once an ideology
is so divorced from what is presented
as you know part of the normal
realm of discourse uh people will
automatically
you know preemptively dismiss it
although that's decreasingly the case
how do you transition from a situation
where we are now to one where there's
ever anarchy at large by definition you
can't have an
anarchist party well sure you can they
have had them in the past
i mean they could just be there to kind
of uh
gin up the works and and you know cause
uh anarchism just means voluntary
association
now anarchists are opposed to political
activity but
you can certainly say like look you know
i'm opposed to war but i'm go
this is a case where it's a self-defense
situation so there's the argument to be
made for that with things like voting
um i'm sorry was the start of the
question
trying to work out how you transition oh
how you get there yes so anarchism isn't
a location it's a relationship
and the vast um proportion of our lives
especially in the west are anarchist
you and i have an anarchist relationship
there's no position possibility we're
calling the police
uh if there was some kind of even we
were somewhere together we got violent
we're still not calling the state
if we were at a bar you know i'd get
kicked out of you to get kicked out so
this claim that
all kind of um peace and prosperity is a
function the state
is really from the anarchist perspective
akin to saying well if it wasn't for all
these exorcists we'd all be possessed uh
the norm between human beings is uh
peace uh not on a large scale because
that's a function of governments
governments give war
um but we generally tend to be more
peaceful than not for the simple reason
not because people are basically good
but because violence is expensive
because once there's violence in a
situation then other people who aren't
at all associated
you see this in bar fights like people
jump in to try to quash it
because people understand very easily
that these things tend to escalate and
then it becomes very expensive to
everyone it's asymmetrical
let's put a stop to it you know right
quick um
so how do you get there well there's
certain mechanisms it's delegitimizing
the state
it's encouraging aggression not not
violent aggression but just
interpersonal aggression and hostility
towards agents of the state
it's casting um aspersions upon
democracy and democratic process
and it's not a numbers game so you know
a lot of people
think well you're never getting a
majority to agree with you but
your only your win condition of having a
majority is based on democracy
other systems do not base their win
condition on
having majority of people agree with me
and and they once
every four years go into a ballot box
and flick a switch
it seems like at a small level an
interpersonal level
individual me and you we do have quite a
an anarchist relationship but as you say
when you scale that up
is it is it realistic that you can allow
an entire 330 million person country
to exist like that well you wouldn't
need it's not
it wouldn't be a country at that point
but let me give you an example of how
this is already a status quo
um every country is in a state of
anarchy towards every other country
right so if a canadian kills a an
american in mexico
i don't know what happens you don't know
what happens but we know that there's a
process put in place
so if security was private where would
be a function of your cell phone instead
of your geography
you know if i attacked you on the i have
one security firm you have another one
and we're at someone else's domicile
what would the situation be we don't
know
but we know it would be resolved in
advance without the consumer having to
work it out
for the simple reason that if i'm on one
phone company and you're at another
it works out and we have no idea what
happened behind the scenes
if their goal is to provide security and
you know generate profit
at that they're going to make it as easy
for the users as possible
as opposed to governments who generate
funding
and generate revenue as a function of
creating problems and creating stress
and having that as an excuse to raise
taxes and uh
seize more assets from the populace does
anarchism need capitalism
in order to facilitate that then no um
the original anarchists were violently
anti-capitalist
um and they viewed capitalism you know
in a sense more similar to what we would
call nowadays corporatism
uh and their analysis of this is spot on
2020 we saw
the systemic destruction of medium and
small businesses
that was cheered on by corporate america
both with riots and looting here in the
states
and also the code lockdowns it did
wonders for companies like amazon or
walmart
all the little stores here in new york
that i'm a fan of they went out of
business because they couldn't sustain
it
so what uh the original anarchist people
like emma goldman and
and uh even before her bakunin and
people like that kropotkin
what they were concerned about is this
collusion between
large business and the state and in that
regard they are spot on
that this is the worst of all uh um well
not the worst of all worlds but it's
it's pretty darn bad
and by getting rid of the state you can
get rid of that collusion
right because you're you're not going to
have a monopoly
without the government forcing everyone
to be a uh um subscriber to that product
you would have the what governments do
in every industry
is create barriers to entry for smaller
companies
because those offer competition to the
large dinosaurs that have effectively
seized large parts of the market
in the past i had only known the show
last week
and he was talking yeah who i'm sorry
andy no okay yeah yeah
uh and he said that antifa identifies
anarcho communists and revolutionary
marxists
how close or far is this from the
purity of a normal anarchist um it's
closer
than it's pretty darn close a lot of you
know and caps narco capitalists
think antifa doesn't have a right to
call themselves anarchists and and they
certainly do
the early anarchists were very
especially in the uk
uh the term in the uk it was synonymous
with terrorists
uh this is why the sex pistol song you
know anarchy in the uk
was so shocking because there he's
johnny rod is explicitly saying i want
to destroy passersby
it was this and they're also called
nihilists at the time
this was an ideology where we're going
to have violent revolution we're going
to
you know blow up businesses or business
people and assassinate
so there is this very long history for
better for worse
um with the black flag and that um
antifa is in regards to self in some
regards
in some senses as an air too does that
not make it
difficult to try and get people on board
with though if the
thin end of the wedge like the front end
of the funnel is
rioting and looting and violence and
black flags and black bloc
like that doesn't seem like a very fun
world for me to step into
i am disturbed by how
much of a recruiting tool that has now
become um
in america because the
degree to which people have become
comfortable with
violence towards state actors
and people who they regard as opposed to
them is
happening at an astronomical pace
uh when the capital was stormed a couple
of weeks ago
uh the r the protesters riders whatever
you want to call them they put up a
gallows
in front of capitol hill and i think
there is
an enormous sense especially with these
lockdowns
an enormous sense of people becoming
comfortable with the idea
of doing very bad things and i'm
extremely concerned about this
uh because violence follows its own
logic it's not the kind of thing where
you
you know if you just shoot the king
everything resolves itself once you
start going down that road
you no one has any idea where it's going
to end up other than
what you are guaranteed of is more
oppression more violence
innocent people being hurt and it's it's
really something of enormous concern to
me
uh in the beginning of 2021 and because
there is this attempt
by the corporate media here to kind of
sweep it on the rug
and when you have a population that's
become comfortable with the idea of
violence
and they're kind of ignored a they're
going to be able to do it and no one's
going to see it coming
and b they're going to be encouraged to
do it because now they feel that they've
been made invisible nothing to lose
didn't you say at the very beginning
though that being averse to state actors
was part of the anarchist's agenda
yeah but a verse doesn't mean like
shooting people in the head
it means contempt it means do not regard
the cops as heroes
i was on tim pool not that long ago with
alex jones and one of my favorite
british isms is
they call the cops the filth uh in fact
one of this is actually a funny story i
was on the bbc
radio like this would have been 15 years
ago
and i always thought and maybe i'm wrong
that the british are a lot
more culturally liberal than the states
that were all more fuddy-duddies here
maybe this was a misconception and the
interviewer
said oh michael you know this this blog
you have you guys take a lot of shots of
the cops
and i said well it's like my dad i was i
was an immigrant from the soviet union
russia i said my dad always told me
and i said this innocently you know
because i thought this is europe they're
going to have the same perspective as
the
russian perspective my dad always told
me wherever you go wherever you end up
in the world the stupidest people
always the cops the guy audibly gasped
and he said michael this is a family
show
and changed the subject and i was very
surprised
to see that um uh having been the case
but that's the kind of thing i'm talking
about
so carl benjamin says this and i totally
agree with him
that the british are very procedural
like if you look at the there was those
scenes
at the capitol hill riots where the
rioters had broken into the capital
but as they were walking through one of
the main halls our atriums had stayed
inside of the ropes yes
um that is so british that is precisely
the sort of thing that a british person
would do
uh you know they'd they'd uh make sure i
saw a guy
the other day who was outside of a
butcher's shop this is before lockdown
and he was he had gloves on
mask on smoking gloves on mask on
smoking outside of it
very procedural in the way that we go
about things
and um perhaps that's contributed to it
a little bit because obviously the
police are basically the enforcement
of the procedure right what about
so you you mentioned about the capitol
hill and and the other rights that we've
seen over the last year
do you look on that and see it as
a misuse of your particular political
ideology
oh no i think whenever you have
politicians hiding in fear
uh as the way they had the rest of us
hiding in fear in their are locked in
our homes for a year uh the imagery
there cannot ever be unseen
uh everyone is gonna stand there and
tell you how strong the regime is and
how powerful it is
and when you have 20 people who can just
walk into the capitol including a guy
from burning man i think
literally he was a burning man person
this demonstrates
that for better for worse this is not a
system that is going to be able to
protect you and that is the big selling
point
of the state it's that you give up your
choices and we're going to keep you safe
uh big brothers watching i know they
have that those signs unironically in
london
and it's like well they're they're lying
to you so if they can't even keep these
you know d-list barbarians out from
their you know sacred temple
they're not going to be able to protect
you and this is going to cause a lot of
people to recalibrate or
their view of the state and the state
authorities
so you see people break into the capitol
building or
take downtown uh portland or
create a capital hill autonomous zone
how do you stop people from losing so
much faith
in society as a whole that they become
nihilistic even if they don't
necessarily subscribe to the anarchist
movement you just think oh god like i
had all of my faith in the state and now
what have i got left to support me
well that's the goal is to have them to
lose all faith in the state now if
there's people whose entire sense of
identity
was faith in the state and now they feel
lost i can't help you you're not
one of my people uh i think both of
those
positions are untenable and and kind of
sad
um but i think once you you know it's
like everyone leaving home
it's like once you realize that this is
all a sham
this is enormously liberating because
now you're either free to
or in a negative sense are forced to
confront your own destiny and confront
your own choices
um this is one of the things that drove
people crazy about
you know uh these masks they're being
told this is giving you a sense
if you follow orders you're going to be
safe it doesn't matter what the efficacy
is
what matters is i get to be obedient and
in turn i'm being guaranteed
that my life isn't in danger it's it's
nonsensical
um but that's where we are is there a
value of despair
that newly indoctrinated anarchists tend
to slip into
there must be a point at which you go
right okay all of the old rules are gone
and none of the new rules and the new um
freedoms
liberties that must come along with
being an anarchist
have they haven't arrived yet well yeah
but that's not exclusive to anarchism
that's the
the dangerous cynicism right once you
realize
you know you lied to all your life and
it's not mistakes systemically
lied to there's the danger of getting
into this stupid catcher in the rye
mindset everyone's a phony this all
sucks i'm gonna listen to you know
the cure uh right in my diary with
fingerless gloves
so my goal
is to kind of speak to those people and
be like like slap them beside the head
metaphorically and be like you're being
silly uh this is teenage
you know nonsense and now is your
opportunity to be an adult and
make your mark on the world or just find
your bliss
given that the capital hill riots have
been probably he
managed to beat even the election
and covid in terms of news coverage over
a short period of time
what do you think people should have
taken away from that
that there is that trump was
the they thought trump was the river but
he was the
damn they thought trump was the source
of all this kind of
um uh um all the things that they hated
and that once you get like he's in i've
used this matter before he's like the
head vampire
once you go with the head vampire all
the other vampires dissolve
and you can return to what you perceive
as normal there's not going to be a
return
you the enemy class will never have this
absolute power they had before
even anywhere near it uh increasingly
people are becoming not just hostile to
them
but how do you have a conversation with
someone
who doesn't just distrust you but is
completely uninterested in anything you
have to say
i don't see how you can put that
humpty dumpty back together again and i
think that is going to be
so their only metric is silence the
opposition right
if because basically if you have two
options and then i get rid of one
by default everyone's going to go to me
well it's very hard
to silence an entire population
in a world where there's technology
entire internet based on allowing people
the opportunity
to speak and present their points of
view i don't see how it's done and it's
also
and the left historically understood
this when you drive a population
underground
and they have nothing to lose this is
going to radicalize them
and blow up in very dangerous ways so i
have thought for a long time what i
would do
if i were you know the corporate press
to try to
reintegrate this population society and
they're basically doing
the complete opposite of what i would
advise and i'm not surprised because if
they're capable of learning
they wouldn't be the enemy class what
would you advise let's say that michael
malus gets put in charge of the media
how do you bring sure the disaffected
groups back in
i would have some sort of it would be
tough
because since i have for decades been
you know advocating for war lying to a
population
just brazenly shamelessly go to their
children it's gonna be really hard to
get them back on board
but i would do things like i would take
some sort of marginal figures
and put them in some kind of ceremonial
position and pretend okay we're going to
make an effort to reintegrate
um i would uh
stop trying to
i would have these places where people
could have these discussions but try to
build as many moats around them as
possible
instead of trying to silence them
completely let them talk to each other
but try to have that talking not reach
the mainstream consensus
that's going to be hard um and i would
try
stop trying to do things like if you're
sitting there talking about calls for
vengeance
and people can hear you this is really
gonna give them an incentive to strike
first
right because then it becomes
self-defense so all of twitter was all
about we have to persecute these people
we have to drive
josh harley from the senate ted cruz
from the senate we have to make sure
this never happens again it's like
trump's numbers went up
from in terms of the voting share from
to 2016.
so you really have a problem if for four
years
of going after someone who is not
particularly a good person or a nice
person
and he had more people voting for him
the second time around
strategically whatever approach you had
did not work
because it did even though he did lose
the election it did not
decrease the number of people who are
comfortable
going in that ballot box and for
whatever reason flicking that switch on
his behalf
is that not the maddest thing that the
media legacy media the left
everybody threw everything that they had
at that election kitchen sink went the
cat went the baby and the bathwater
and only just scraped through
a democratic victory yeah and they lost
uh a huge a significant number of seats
in the house
joe biden is the last time this the
incoming president didn't have the
senate he has a 51-50 but you know this
is marginal
was richard nixon so that is not a
governing consensus in the house it's
something like
219 to 212. uh these are
i mean and because it's you know here in
the states
each party is basically coalitions of
different groups
219 democrats is not as cohesive and
coherent as people think because you're
going to have different wings and
they're going to have different
perspectives and
it's going to be very very hard to get
that majority through especially in the
senate where one person and you're done
and every senator of course represents
different states and has different egos
so it is um amazing and
the the articles were already written if
there had been any metric
other than losing of course where trump
kind of went down
trumpism has been repudiated the
american people come to their senses
they were just champing at the bit and
yes biden won
and they tried to put that over but it
fell completely on deaf ears
and again i don't know what they can do
to get people listening to them
um again naval ravikant on rogan
said this quote and he didn't cite where
it's from but it's the best thing that
i've heard around this
he said the left won the culture war now
they're just driving around shooting the
survivors
yeah uh i don't know that they won the
culture war they
created culture historically yeah the
bright just didn't bother getting
involved
right and the thing is there's an
enormous asymmetry between right and
left
because when there's left wing like
cultural violence
it's rioting but when you have
right-wing cultural violence it gets
really ugly really really fast because
they're not playing
they're playing for keeps and it's it's
quick and it's very brutal
so i am desperately hoping
it doesn't reach that point and i don't
see any mechanisms of it slowing down
that's precisely what i've said for the
last few months this tit for tap
mechanism
i do a thing to you you do it back to me
a little bit more i do it back to you a
little bit more
and it just escalates and what have you
got left
there's only two ways that things happen
it can either be dictatorial top down or
it can be emergent bottom up
the culture's not slowing down we've got
frictionless communication which permits
everyone to go from brain to fingertip
or mouth
to internet world with basically
absolutely no restrictions at all that
on its own
accounts for an awful lot of why we're
seeing more vitriol online like we're
not
built to have our thoughts be broadcast
to the entire world like you shouldn't
do it think about
200 years ago you'd get a quill out a
piece of paper
and maybe like a pigeon or a raven or
something like that and you would send
it to the local battlements like
if you're gonna say something you better
make sure that it actually is meaningful
you can't just like toilet tweet
something that ends up going viral and
getting you in loads of trouble
yeah is this about when you guys burned
down the white house because we haven't
forgotten about it
i didn't know that russia had a had a
white house
yeah it's the crystal palace i think
yeah yeah there's that new 1 billion
pound palace man i want to get on to
that obviously i had a
a guy called john sweeney who was the
bbc's correspondent for panorama out in
russia
for quite a while and um he was telling
me about this alexa navalny thing
before that what do you think about this
whole chaos of
gamestop and wall street bets and then
today we found out about the market
trying to shut the traders down is this
a digital form of anarchy
uh i don't know if it's anarchy per se
but it's certainly um
any time people's pompous posturing
and their beat i've been following it
closely because i know
once i sit down for and follow this
story through from everyone who's been
forwarding to me
like my pants are gonna be ruined
because i'm just it's gonna
downright pornographic like everyone's
like you don't understand this is what
you've been predicting and calling for
so i'm i need to sit down where i have
nice uh
pants you wanted a separate ball ball
and
yeah sheath underwear yeah yeah yeah
because this is
this is everyone's like you this is
exactly what you like
um whenever pomposity and pretension
which is a form of deceit is undermined
especially in a populist way or just by
in a clever way
this is something i absolutely adore i
don't think this is all exclusive to you
know anarchism per se
um but it's wonderful um
so i and what else is very useful
is it's a lot i think we're a lot closer
to brave new world than 1984.
it's a lot easier to manipulate a
population through pleasure than through
force and through oppression if you just
give them a little bit of cheese and
you give them a job it's going to be
very hard to get them to be riled up and
you could just milk them
all day long so whenever
if you're going to win a war as i intend
to
or i hope to it's of enormous utility
when they take the gloves off and they
have to demonstrate
that underneath they're perfectly happy
to use brute force or whatever
just be unsophisticated like okay we're
just going to shut it down
and then it becomes a lot easier to
demonstrate that these people don't give
a damn about you
uh they're out looking for their own
best interests which is their
prerogative but this pretense this
corporate bs
that we're all in this together and blah
blah blah it's just complete sociopathy
and nonsense
and a lot of people will never
appreciate this and that's fine but you
don't want them on your team anyway
a lot of people who can be one over
they're going to see things like this
and they're gonna be like okay like i'm
starting to get it like this is just a
complete facade
i'm trying to work out what the
particular quirk is
in with my makeup i think it is partly
being british and enjoying the procedure
i'm also moderately orderly i'm an
orderly guy my bedroom tends to be tidy
and i put things away in rows in the
cupboard and stuff like that
um and for me i enjoy watching people
like
alex jones i enjoy learning about
alternative world views and i enjoy
questioning at least indulging myself in
thought experiments around what is the
state's ulterior motives and stuff like
that
but it does feel usually a little bit
like
watching a pantomime you're like yeah
yeah like that looks good but i know
that the
guys will go backstage and take their
clothes off and it'll all just be normal
like the way that i know the world's to
be once it's kind of all finished
but increasingly there are things
happening and this is such a stark
example
you see the market move which is
quantifiable which makes it really
interesting because you can actually
see what's happening it's not just a
sentiment right it's not just how people
feel it's
quantifiable metrics they're in front of
you and you see this market move
and then these different structures of
power start to come in
so robin hood decide that they're going
to stop trading and then
other platforms say that they're going
to stop trading and then there's
questions about circuit breakers being
put into the market so that they can
stop the price moving at
all he's seeing people 50 percent of
robin hood clients
hold some gamestop stock
so by stopping that trading not allowing
anyone else to buy you're just sending
the price in one direction
like it and then the the most
interesting thing about it all
is that when you have a distributed
network
of people who have far too much time on
their hands and are smarter than they
are kind of moronic like they all call
themselves like a proud community of
artists
but like you don't want to [ __ ] with
those people they know they're not going
to forget anything
they they know they know what they're
talking about they just can't look you
in the eye whilst they say it
i whilst i had a chapter about this in
my last book about gamergate
because part of the evangelical left is
the idea that these prince of political
principles have to be
implemented in every aspect of your life
including sci-fi and fantasy and movies
so even places you go to escape the
earth you know these edicts have to be
followed through
one of the examples i used which you
know you want to talk about autism i got
it right here
was on star trek they finally had a they
finally
that's the word they used had a black
vulcan and if you want to go full
autistic the idea that human race is
evolved in parallel and other planets is
absolute
right if you're gonna if you're gonna
look at it from that perspective from
their perspective no
you have to have diversity even though
if it makes no sense there was a video
game
that took place in the middle ages of of
of europe
and they were complaining there wasn't
enough diversity there as well so it
becomes completely
you know very top-down and uh um
nonsensical so this when
you know the corporate journalists came
for this community
like you were saying this is an entire
population with too much time in their
hands
who also spend their time trying to
figure out
how the the enemy in this case in the
video games the enemy works
and what weapons do i need to do to
conquer this enemy they don't look at it
in terms
so it becomes a game to them it's like
okay let's just do a b testing let's try
different tactics
and it's decentralized so you have an
army of these people it's like al qaeda
right there's no
you can't kill the one guy and
everything falls away they're used to
this they've been training for it their
entire lives
right they have this is our moment right
but no i mean literally just spending
hours trying to accomplish these goals
that have been set for them
with adversaries in the way so it's a
beautiful
um you know one of the things you and i
talk about
you know uh personally is kind of this
whole
generation who they're getting more
attention but they're kind of being told
that they don't exist
are these kind of alienated young males
right so
in some cases it goes in a very very bad
direction you know you kind of have this
white nationalism
this sense of oh your life is bad
because there's too many minorities and
now
this racial identity means you can look
at what your grandfather supposedly did
now you're a great person
but this is another example you could be
at your
desktop your what they call them like
workstation
and you can cause systemic carnage
against some really nasty people and
have lulls at the same time isn't that
great
so i i am a big fan of uh
i don't know about the specifics of this
case to be honest but
i'm a big fan of this ethos
it is i think the first time that you
heard about it was me telling you
perhaps or
maybe trey yeah mutual buddy is also a
big
wall street bets follower but i spoke
about it last year i'd seen some mad
[ __ ] that they'd done last year
these guys what is it they call like
4chan founder bloomberg terminal
they call themselves and uh yeah it
really is
they're they're your people they're your
people that could be the party of malice
there
there's 3.5 million of them in that
subreddit now
it's a wonderful thing and that's what
else is hilarious they're like well
we'll just shut up shut down this
subreddit
as if somehow on the internet there's
any shortage of places to create
communities
when you have 3.5 million people let's
propose one percent of our programmers
like how hard is it gonna be where all
they're interested in doing is being
able to text each other they're not
trying to build spaceships
they just need a space to exchange
information where there's a worldwide
infrastructure designed to facilitate
this as you said earlier it's it's
glorious
did you see that ja rule got involved
today i did
i i'm not really sure who he is for
racist reasons i'm assuming he's a
rapper
he is yeah he was his trend was filed
under hip-hop
i mean that's fairly that's fairly
racist by twitter it had nothing to do
with hip-hop
like you know he's an entrepreneur he's
a budding entrepreneur he's part of fire
festival
yeah someone oh okay someone posted the
dave chappelle bit going like why the
[ __ ] do i care about what jar rule
thinks at this moment it's from one of
his old stand-ups
it was just an entire thread of people
posting that below
it's i i think that's also this great
thing you know blue pill red build
it's like you're sitting at home and you
have some people political perspectives
are one kind or another
but then it's like why am i getting
political orders
from actors who are puppets made out of
meat like it makes
no sense on any level and it's such an
insincere
propaganda technique that i think people
increasingly and i'm doing what i can
start to resent it it would make more
sense if
someone was a writer of these sitcoms
because writers have to create a
narrative
writers have to be coherent and logical
writers to some extent have to be in
touch with the
reality an actor you you don't really
you have no original thoughts or the
thoughts you do have
aren't part of your job it feels to me
like there's a common thread and i
haven't worked out what it is but a
common thread through
a lot of what we're seeing at the moment
i spoke to john sweeney who like i said
is the russia
correspondent or used to be x for
panorama bbc
and um he was talking about alexei
navalny who's just gone back to
his home country and was immediately
i can't keep saying russia because you
make me laugh
um he went back to his home country was
immediately
uh arrested upon arrival the we've had
the
capitol hill we've had the capitol hill
autonomous zone we've had
portland riots we've had this that we're
seeing happening with wall street bets
the iterative speed of the devolving of
what used to be these structures is this
one common thread is there something
going on and what is it
you hit the nail on the head i mean
that's a very good insight
because states are not quick actors
a lot of times with these covet for
example let's suppose you know every
aspect of emergency is actually exactly
as it's presented
you have governors issuing these edicts
but even in that case this is a very
dynamic
system where the virus you know the one
state is going to go down it's going to
be another state
it's very very hard and no one will deny
this
for any kind of government to act or
react
to a dynamic situation compared to that
to twitter
uh someone on twitter or someone on
reddit or something like that
yeah where you have all these people
it's decentralized everyone can be on
top of it and the information spreads
more quickly
whereas with the state you have to have
you know fauci and then this has to go
out and then you have to go over the
press release and check the wording
it's never going to be and it can't
really be
because it has to be official and by the
book and you're talking about the whole
government
the whole country it really has to be
you know a very
proper process as opposed to this kind
of
free process which i'm more of a fan of
and that's an enormous asymmetry
you know by the time something reaches
biden's desk these guys will be moving
on
i mean think about how many um hoops
something has to jump through before it
reaches boris johnson's attention
there's an entire process in place he's
got his cabinet you know and
all his assistants to make sure the only
things that reach his attention
are things that require the pm's direct
attention
at the same time they're not necessarily
going to have
the foresight like you did to be like
wait a minute
this is something that's up and coming
because to them they're not spending
time on reddit they don't know the
internet
so this is gonna be completely hit them
upside the head out of nowhere
and by the time they're like let's sit
down and figure out how to react it's
two weeks later
and they've already moved on this is
this is another reason i'm so
enormously optimistic about the future
of the west
is it a function of frictionless
communication
is it something inherent to do with the
population growth being where it is
is it the fact that everyone's got
access to information and knowledge so
that there aren't these gated
communities of understanding anymore
have you got any sense of why people
this common
common thread appears to be occurring i
think it's a lot of is also
the enormous disconnect between
how people in power are presented
as moral superior
um people who should be listened to and
obeyed as opposed to reality
and when you have this enormous
disconnect and it gives people the
opportunity a undermine it
and b enjoy themselves and feel
empowered that they're doing something
about it
this is a very dangerous combo for uh
the elites
how do you avoid that's something i just
thought of how do you avoid
normlessness and meaninglessness within
an anarchistic society because
if you're stripping back a lot of the
previous institutions that people would
have relied on to find their sense of
self
and both me and you were big proponents
of personal sovereignty and upward
agency and
all that sort of stuff but it you know
we have to concede that that
isn't for everybody some people require
those bigger structures to hold
themselves together
how would you propose supporting those
people
oh i don't support them i don't care
about them they're ballast they're they
don't really
[ __ ] publish
they are we have brilliant ideas that
break
yeah they bring nothing well that's a
pejorative they bring nothing to the
table
um and you know if they were in uh
maybe iran they'd be radical jihadis and
if they're in
britain they're this and the american
they're this they don't really
think critically and that's fine but in
terms of what could be done for them i
mean
i i don't really know i can't empathize
with with them
whatever system works out like they will
just
obey whatever is the rules of the game
and they will
they will be able to kind of follow suit
and they'll watch the sitcoms
and you know and live this kind of
docile cow-like life
um but i don't spend much time uh
thinking about them this is something
that i
stress a lot with you know people who
are followers of mine they're like look
at all these people who are mindless
and i'm like how are these mindless
people a threat to you like they're
they're they're no they're like trees
like
if are you like well we can't win
because there's all these trees it's
like what does that have to do with
anything
like any population an enormous percent
enormous percentage of it
is going to be with people who really
are in a very fundamental way mindless
who have no
kind of inner voice who are opposed or
incapable this is a big argument are
they imposed or incapable
of thinking critically and our you know
h.l menken the great american kind of
cynic from the early 20th century
said has this great quote about the
average man does not want to be free he
simply wants to be safe
and i think you're seeing that a lot
more in britain sadly than in the states
nowadays
how they really want to be told what to
do
and kind of like just follow suit and i
know you're you know an entrepreneur
and kind of really trying to become much
more self-actualized and
you've talked to me about this this is
something that you find uh
it's not only frustrating to be
surrounded by it
but it's also maddening in the sense of
like how are you like this
like we are so blessed with so many
opportunities
and you just want to watch you know uh
celebrity big brother
and whatnot and and just you know have a
pint and then go to bed
not there's anything wrong with that but
that's their highest that's their
highest desperation i
i love trashy tv i love having a
drink or whatever but there there's a
time and a place for both
my tragedy the tragedy that i see is
people doing that
every decade for three or four in a row
that to me is
is a life wasted um yes and it's their
life to waste
but it still doesn't mean necessarily
that i need to
be an advocate or supportive in any way
of it i wonder
whether it's a particularly british
phenomenon
i can't speak for other people other
nations maybe some of the people can let
us know in the comments from where
they're from and and
how they find their culture with regards
to this total lack of personal
sovereignty and upward mobility
uh and an ability to do anything sort of
uh laterally as well to think like okay
here is the path that i'm on let's just
see what happens if i take a big left
turn
let's just see maybe maybe it totally
wrecks everything but maybe it's
actually not that bad
and um i've had this idea for a while
that it's because we're water locked
because we're quite a small nation
because the weather's quite bad the even
if you're looking at excuses
no so this is me this is me saying what
are the things that feed it into the
british culture
i know but these are right but you know
what i mean like we'll all you'll always
find a reason not to achieve
or not to hope or not to think
critically there's no shortage ever
do you see this can you imagine like
someone saying like the reason i don't
want to
aspire to you know run my own like
toffee shop is because of the weather
i get that but we're mimetic creatures
right mimetic desire is a big thing
and i feel like in a place that had
more there was more cosmopolitan for
instance as one thing if you had a
bigger country with more
international visitors you may have more
people coming and going that would
actually be able to broaden your mindset
if you had slightly better weather
people would be able to do
more things outside of just like at the
moment it's
dark at 8am and 4 30 p.m
and it's raining all day every day there
isn't a massive amount of stuff that you
can do
if you could perhaps that would broaden
your perspective maybe i don't just need
to go
pub netflix work pub netflix work
yeah you're not going to tell me
london's not international enough i mean
this this is it it's really and
there's so i love british culture and in
fact i've been to the uk once
and i did not have a good time and i
interviewed aria she was from
the band the slits old school punk band
johnny rotten's um
step daughter and she said yeah i'm not
gonna do her accent she had this
jamaican accent she passed away not that
long ago
and she said yeah we all hated london
we couldn't wait to get the [ __ ] out of
there her words and she's like no wonder
you didn't have a good time
and to me the the the
best thing about uh britain
is how it you know you know obviously
the british empire i'm sure something
has very mixed
uh emotional people uh residents of
people from england
but the idea that you had all these
countries
from all over the world under the sway
of the queen
or whoever the king was at the time and
you imported elements to it to britain
and it made this kind of cosmopolitan
culture like tea time
you know coming from japan and and i
mean music and
the british museum are you kidding me
it's just it's just
an amazing miracle of civilization so
i i i don't buy into that at all just
because it's
if the rain is going to stop you from
like becoming a better person
it's not the rain it's a good point i
think
i might be slightly jaded because i'm in
newcastle which is the last city before
scotland
and there is a very much a small town
mentality
as soon as you get pretty much out of
london you go to
even the bigger cities manchester
birmingham you have people
like born live die well aren't those
kind of like
like [ __ ] i mean aren't they like
really kind of
like relics of what they used to be and
that they're kind of very depressing
used to be much more industrial
uh and this kind of economic okay i
think that's most of the uk man like
you know yeah really what have we got we
it's not like we have natural resources
the only thing that we can export is our
intellect and our accent
like those those are the two biggest
exports that we have
my friend was is a mick ronson's
daughter he was bowie's guitarist and he
was from hull
and she's like you don't understand like
what it's like going there she's like
it's
it's like maybe it's like detroit but
it's really like you go
you know when the sex pistols sing about
there's no future there are those places
in the uk and you'd obviously know it's
better than i do
where you grow up and it's in those
cases the weather does matter
because if everything's run down and the
weather sucks and it's dark it's very
hard to see
sunshine and emotional levels so i'll
i'll accept that certainly
moving forward what are the main changes
that you think people should expect
especially in the american media and
culture without trump
in office anymore obviously we had this
knife edge that it was could it go one
way could it go another
and four more years we could have
probably had a good understanding of
what to expect just more of the same
but now that he's no longer there what
do you reckon is going to happen
it's it is going to be so demented this
year
that people have no idea uh
what's coming it's been what two weeks
into the biden administration
and we're already seeing like they're
talking about putting on second masks
and you know what we're just seeing with
gamestop and so on and so forth
um the thing with chaos and chaos and
anarchy you're not synonymous but i'm a
fan of both
is you never know you know where it's
going to be coming one of my favorite
moments of the trump
um presidency was there was some dispute
between him and the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
and there was an entire busload of
democratic congressmen
and they were going to take a plane to
visit an american base i think maybe in
iraq or something
and trump as commander-in-chief pulled
the authorization from the military
plane
so they had to bring the bus back to the
capital they all had to get off the bus
like the school trip has been canceled
and we were just sitting there peeing
our pants as all these congressmen just
didn't know what because they had they
had to get off the bus and that had to
be on video
and it was just a complete humiliation
no one could have predicted that
so i think without trump without this
centralized figure
we are going to see things like you were
talking about this wall street vet stuff
so many more um
attempts and successful executions of
things that are no one saw coming and
are going to be hilarious
and that will demonstrate how much of
the
um claim to elite control is completely
fraudulent
that these people are not better that
they're not particularly smarter
they're certainly not more moral uh and
the more that's exposed the more hopeful
people become from the future because
it's one thing to say
look you're going to be ruled by a bunch
of thieves
fine you know maybe you need that maybe
you need those deeds in charge to make
sure like
i'd rather have the thieves than the
murderers right but
let's be honest that you are thieves and
that i think is would be a good starting
point to go forward and i think that's
increasingly happening
what's the difference between a trump
administration and a biden
administration why does a biden
administration
garner more chaos than the trump one i
would have thought the trump
would have been more chaotic because
with trump
um people who would
have disdain for the system a large part
of them felt represented
they felt okay we have someone who
thinks like i do we have someone who
hates the things i hate he's speaking
for me i have a voice
now they feel like okay no one's
speaking for me i have
no commitment to this system i have no
investment here
i'm being told i'm a white supremacist
insurrectionist on a daily basis so okay
if that's how you regard if i'm
not if you regard me as a nazi if you're
going to read me out of the human race
then we can't really go forward having a
conversation i don't want to
sit down have a conversation with the
nazi well i did for my book but not
certainly in a collegial kind of way
like oh you know where
were your kids going to school oh nice
seeing you so on and so forth so
i think it's going to be much more uh
systemic
breaking down and we're seeing in europe
so if you follow european elections
it's becoming harder and harder for
different countries to form governing
coalitions
um belgium was the great example where
there's two halves of belgium from
getting this country right one
was socialist the other now the white
nationalists were in charge because they
speak different languages
you're not going to be able to sit down
and work with each other we had this
in thiringia and germany where they had
a negative coalition meaning
the far left and the afd the
nationalists had enough seats that
between them no one could make a
majority
and they didn't know what to do so and
now in italy
what's happening is for a long time you
had um
berlusconi's party right he was the
center right party uh before
italia uh you know they were the right
wing ones and then as it was
after he kind of fell away you had
matteo salvini the league
you guys are nazis you guys are nazis
you guys are nazis they got into
government
well what happened then is now that they
recall the nazis
they're losing some support but the
neo-fascists are gaining support
so when you are forcing people to pay
the costs
of having views that are extreme at a
certain point they're gonna be like you
know what i am gonna check these people
out because that's what you're calling
me
and they're the ones who want to talk to
me and you don't this is a very
dangerous game these people are playing
um and they are so up their own ass
and are so not used to thinking
strategically that all they
know how to do is just repeat what
they've said before and i
all i could do is caution and be like
you are doing a very
dangerous thing and i'm saying this as
an anarchist who does not believe in
politics
that feels like an element of the thread
that we were talking about earlier on
that you have such a rapid pace emerges
yes on the bottom
and you have such a big lumbering
goliath up at the top
yeah that's exactly it and this huge
disconnect and this goliath
is complete if there's like i'm a big
zoology person
and the thing that brings down giraffes
are ticks
because in giraffe the surface area of a
giraffe is enormous that means you could
have so many ticks on it draining of
blood giving a disease
it's going to be a lot easier for that
than for let's suppose a lion where if
the giraffe kicks in the head it once
it's dead
so this is i i i think they're
completely oblivious
uh they're always tell themselves in
these words that they're on the right
side of history
you know if someone comes up to me with
a knife telling them i'm on the right
side history is really going to be a
very weak tool
and if it is a war just saying i'm the
good guys
is really not going to gain you anything
so that's what's happening emergently
that's what sort of the the population
is feeling
what about top down what do you see in
terms of administrative
changes or i guess top-down cultural
changes
i'm shocked by how quickly they've come
to realize
that wait a minute we didn't win because
they thought very sincerely we got rid
of trump everything could go back to
normal
unity and then it took a couple of weeks
and they're like holy crap none of these
trump people
who or who they described as trump
people like you know they would call
glenn greenwald a trump person none of
these people missed a beat
uh they're not going home they're not
going anywhere uh they've become
even more radicalized uh they become
even more contemptuous of us
what do we do well and they're not
really they're just i think at this
point they're still confused
and they're going to become a lot more
confused or
they're going to start implementing
smart strategies which i wouldn't bet on
uh if they want to if they know what's
good for them and i don't say that as a
threat i'm saying i'm saying
that someone who's very afraid are you
seeing this with the amount of executive
orders
that biden's put in for instance that
it's just a hammer blow
it's using i'm seeing here's another
example like uh
for three years we heard that the 2016
election was
you know undermined by russia and there
was trump was impeached over this and
russia russia russia russia there's a
conspiracy and there was collusion with
trump and putin within a week of this
past election
every corporate media outlet was saying
this has been the most secure election
history
it is not possible to make that
statement with that quickly
you haven't invested it might be true
but you couldn't in a week
you know do all the investigations see
all the mistakes see whatever was fixed
and how was it that president trump and
all these republican governors
oversaw it going from russia to now it's
completely secure
this is a clearly and to just to
dispute this in any way is grounds from
getting you removed from
social media and so you should be
silenced and now you believe in
insurrection and civil war and all this
other stuff
this is not the approach of an elite
that feels secure
and in control this is someone if
you if someone if you and me are having
an argument in your house
i'll say my piece you'll see your piece
you know maybe our voices will get
raised
if i'm shoving you out of the house and
locking the door i don't feel safe
and that's what they are trying to do
the problem is they don't really own the
house anymore
like they do not have a monopoly over
the mechanisms of
um conversation and that when you have
an edifice built on deception being able
to speak
even critically is an enormous
existential threat to it
are we seeing again this is another one
of those threads that appears to be
tying together
the same way as executive orders the
same way as
restrictions with regards to speech the
same way as the press restricting
people's movements the same way as robin
hood restricting people's trades
is this the last vestiges of the old
guard
trying to hold on to their version of
power or how they used to be able to
deploy power
and it seems like if they were to go
about it in a more smart way
this is the 1984 element of a brave new
world
the fact that there is only so far that
you can try to cajole and coerce and
and tempt people into things until you
need to get the hammer out and hit him
over the head
yeah and we're seeing a lot more hammers
appear
and that as you said is when it's really
really obvious that someone's decided
okay
gloves are off rules are broken i need
to i need to press the [ __ ]
ejector c button and it's also very
expensive in the sense of if
you and i have a fight whatever hey
sorry man i was really upset no no
it's cool if you punch me in the face or
i punch you in the face you can never
undo that
and that's also shown me several things
one you're a person who's capable of
violence against me or vice versa
and you're someone who is can do that
again in the future
this is not it goes very hard to reverse
that
and to try to have some kind of
relationship that's at all based on
respect
or working together it's like all right
you did this to me once
also now there's an enormous pressure i
have to make sure
i'm not in that position again because
i'm sorry it was a mistake it's like you
know what if i get punched a second time
at some point
it's going to be part of my fault that i
trusted you so this is
when they have to use this kajo like you
pointed out or this hammer
this is enormously expensive on that for
them in terms of future relationships
because that is something that can't be
unseen or undone you can't ring that
bell
and it's not just necessarily the person
who gets the cudgel out
right it's everybody else within
that domain and perhaps this is why
we're seeing such a proliferation
of telegram and discord and signal you
know i've i saw
i can't remember who let me give you a
great example this hold on look so one
of the big things i've been
working on this past year was uh turning
people against the police
and i have never seen any population
switch its views on a fundamental issue
as quickly
as in america at least conservatives
have turned the police
for a very long time you could not talk
them about it
the police are what keeps us from being
you know in a state of anarchy haha
a state of complete violence everyone be
killing each other and then all you had
to do was a little bit of footage
there was canada where they broke into
someone's house because they were having
thanksgiving dinner whatever it was
and pulled an old man out of the house
and when you see that video it's like
okay
i can never pretend some people still
can that
okay they're keeping us safe they're
just like you and me
good apples you look at that you're like
i don't know you don't have to know
anything about politics
to know something somewhere has taken a
very drastic turn
when old people who are not you know gun
runners or drug dealers or running a
brothel
are being violently pulled out of their
homes by the police
this is not like you're it's like you're
doing accounting
and all of a sudden you have like a
million dollar deficit it's like okay
somewhere the math went way wrong
the trust's getting eroded away quite
quickly and it can never be rebuilt
and it would appear that that's
happening across all different
institutions
that the legacy media posts something
which erodes a little bit of trust in
the government and then the government
put a policy in that people don't like
that means that they're a little bit
less sure about when the police come
round
and you're seeing this with just
generally the way that people respond
to police uh talking about mask
mandates like if you see someone that
they're angry but they're not angry at
the policeman
or even at the police at hole like they
know that it's not their legislation
but they just see the man they see
whoever is person in charge as this top
down dictatorship
dictatorial bureaucratic organization
that's trying to get them to do [ __ ]
one thing that i've been really
interested in over the last year
of watching you you're a passionate new
yorker and you've lived there forever
and
you never considered living anywhere
else when we first started speaking
has that changed over the last year yeah
as
you and i have discussed and and it's uh
what has the governor
and the mayor have done more damage to
new york than al qaeda has
i i say this not ironically um
what i loved about new york i've lived
here since i was two
i don't even need to tell people people
know why new york's great and i'm sure
everyone has a story about why new york
sucks but
the things that make new york great
everyone knows what i'm gonna say that's
been
devastated not only that my social
network my all my friends
you know what keeps me sane they've all
moved out i'm like i'm like one of the
few ones left standing so
um it's not that i'm leaving new york
it's that the new york i love and fell
in love with is gone
it causes me pain physically to see what
they've done to this city
and all the cool spots i've went to um
so
i don't know where i would go
what i'm going to start doing uh being
fortunate to have the kind of career
i do is i'm gonna be spending like a
week
every month in a different city and
trying it out um i'm
hearing good things i can't believe this
is something i'd ever consider again if
a year ago you told me this i'd be like
okay whatever there
um like miami i'm hearing good things
about that
i'm gonna be in austin for a week uh
next week or
in a week from next week la of course
did you work but
uh we shall see if europe opens up i had
a supporter who tossed me a grand who
goes this will be enough to live in
europe for a month
so i'm sure you and i could spend a week
at some cool
eastern european place and and really
have a fun time with it the russia stuff
is going to be
much more emotional and personal
biographical you know it's going to be a
very different resonance
but you know one of these like balkan
places it's
i think we would just lose our minds and
have fun do you not agree
absolutely yeah i mean travel's such a
big part of my life and
it yeah i'm able to take a fair bit of
discomfort
like i i pride myself on being able to
kind of get my head down and crack on
into that puritan work ethic again
but even for me
the last few months have started to
really drag on dark knight cold weather
gyms shut um like completely shut and
unable to go outside
unable to train at least over last year
when the gyms were shut we could go out
into the garden and
get a workout in with slightly [ __ ]
equipment
whereas now it's like there's nothing um
so
i'm starting my cut today so i'm going
to catch up with you soon i heard
i saw i saw online what are your
calories what are you cutting at
uh we only dropped 500 um so it's down
to 200 protein
and let me see i'm pulling the document
i have the documents it's going to be 2
900
uh calories per day for now that's still
good so you're gonna feel fine at that
oh yeah yeah it's i mean when we i have
to get to that kind of
we'll see what happens it's gonna be a
process
i've been watching over the last year
and trying to get the best tips that i
can
from you on trolling just passively i
haven't tried
yeah yeah because trolling russia
come on don't tell us we can't pronounce
trolling
i don't know where that accent's
supposed to be i think that's like it's
jordy mixed with scottish
yeah okay fine anyway that thing that
thing subtitled it
that thing that you do when you quote
tweet people and you say stuff
i've been that's not trolling i mean to
be pedantic
okay well why don't you give me your
definition of it and then also what are
your principles behind it how can i
become a better troll
i think it'd be very hard for you to
become a troll um for
many many different reasons um
but for me trolling is using
someone's flaws in order to turn them
into an unwitting performer
uh for the benefit of a third party so
here's an example
a great example i have this in my book
than you write mountain dew
you know corporate they make soda
they're like hey
um what should the next flavor of
mountain dew be
like vote in the poll and 4chan said
okay
we can do this and they got the number
one answer to be hitler did nothing
wrong
okay and they're not doing this as nazis
because now mountain dew
has to either acknowledge it or they
have to do something about it and they
pull the pole of course and they go okay
looks like the internet won
this round you know so
trolling is like we're talking about the
video games earlier it's an exploit
uh it especially works very well when
people are
low quality people presenting themselves
as high quality
so that disconnect between the
pretension and the product
is an enormous opportunity to get them
to
make an asset themselves uh your boy
pierce morgan i think is
really prime for trolling i think
doesn't everyone in the uk kind of loki
hate him
i think so yeah he he can continually
trends obviously he's on breakfast
tv every single morning and they have a
really clever way itv
have a really smart way where they'll
take clips
from the show and then distribute them
really quickly
on twitter and such that like they trend
they must trend at least once a week
or a couple of times a week sometimes
and even for like just they got some
lads on that were a part of a meme
the other day and that that made that
trend and then he does
proper stuff or he goes off the rails or
he goes on an illegal holiday and stuff
like that
so yeah but he's also a bit of a heel
isn't he doesn't he lean into this kind
of persona
i think he likes the bad guy persona a
little bit but the
the weird thing is it's that's not
necessarily what people tune into
breakfast tv for at least traditionally
it wasn't it is in a fluffy way to enjoy
your yes
of course toasting a coffee on a morning
time you don't want to see
piers waggling his finger in someone's
face and shouting about it
i grew up on roger hargreaves books the
mr men books
so my impression of british culture is
based entirely on those books and my
understanding was it's hard-boiled eggs
no soft-boiled eggs that you all have
for breakfast and you have the egg
holder i don't even know what a soft
boiled egg is that where you put dippy
soldiers in
dippies i don't know what that is like
little strips of toast
yeah yeah you got the egg cup yeah right
you crack the top
okay yeah yeah obviously you have a
misaligned childhood somehow
yeah okay so so peace pierce is someone
that you should go after
but what like let's say because a lot of
the time the people that come after you
you don't know them
so but that's not trolling it's just me
clowning them okay
yeah so i'm just making ass out of them
for everybody's amusement okay um here's
a good example of trolling i'm looking
right now at a signed picture from andy
kaufman who was like one of the great
trolls
so andy kaufman had this um
character tony clifton who was this like
failed lounge singer and he had this bit
where he came he said you know my like
he's got a very particular voice i can't
do it
he's like you know my wife died a few
years ago and whenever i look at my
daughter in the eye i see her
and she's going to come out here we're
going to do a duet together and the
daughter comes out
you know teenage girl sits on his lap
they start singing a song
and her voice cracks and he slaps her
across the face
hard and he's like what are you doing
we're in front of an audience
and then they all they're they're
gobsmacked i think you guys say and they
all start and he goes
stop booing you're just making her cry
more now they don't know what to do
now this not only wasn't his daughter
was an actress who was an adult and this
is a whole thing
but the point is it is exploiting their
very normal
and something he shared you know uh
horror at the idea of a child being hit
uh to turn them all into performers for
his own amusement
so it's chasing that discomfort in a way
it's the office
uh the british the brickager base's
office and many of his shows
they're not trolling per se but they
very much
hit that exact same note of humor where
you're playing with someone's extreme
discomfort
and even when you watch the office you
know these are all actors
you know they're there's not there's no
question in your mind that this isn't
real
but you still at home are just cringing
and like want to jump out of her window
because there was this one
just off top my head there was this one
episode where they had a fire drill
and there's a girl in the wheelchair and
they carry her down one stair lever on
the left right good luck
and there's just the shot of the
cameraman staring down at her and she's
in the stairwell looking up shrugging
her shoulders
and you're just like oh my god i i i
want to die it's so painful and
beautiful
i find that really uncomfortable to
watch that stuff for me is
almost unbearable but i feel like i feel
like my
cringe reflex is hyper-sensitized i
don't know why
okay well that's cause you're a decent
person maybe perhaps yeah
uh final thing man you mentioned on
twitter that you learned something from
me
the other day what was that oh this is a
whole long conversation
we can save it for another time yeah
well i'm gonna i might even talk about
it on a certain other show in a in a few
weeks but i'll
we can yeah so we'll come back we'll
come back to that that's a nice open
loop for the next one
uh talk to me about the book when can
people expect
that is it going to be this i yes i am
half i hope so i'm halfway done
so even if i do just a page a day it'll
be done first draft in three months so i
think it's very realistic it'll be out
this year the white pill
it's about the victory of good over evil
i'm so excited man it's great uh it is
such a pleasure
to have you here um it's uh i'm excited
for russia
i'm excited to see what you do over the
next couple of weeks and then the
forthcoming book release
man everyone that is listening if you
want to go and check out more of
michael's stuff it'll be linked in the
show notes below or leave a comment
and let us know what you think dude
thank you thank you
for being a friend
[Music]